today on the matt walsh show passengers
rejoice as a judge strikes down the cdc
mask mandate this news has provoked yet
more delicious leftist tears but there's
an important lesson we can also take
from all this we'll talk about that
today also americans have wondered for
the past two years who is really running
the white house now we know it's the
easter bunny and a washington post
reporter cried about being doxed and
harassed and then proceeded to dox and
harass the anonymous person behind the
libs of tiktok account we'll talk about
all that and more today on the matt
walsh show
[Music]
well if you're looking to add a little
bit of money to your budget it's a very
good time to consider a mortgage
refinance because believe it or not it's
a rather easy way to save up to a
thousand dollars a month that's right a
thousand dollars a month here's how it
works you call america financing for a
free mortgage review no pressure no
obligation no upfront or hidden fees
just a simple conversation with a salary
based mortgage consultant where you
learn about custom loans that may be a
better fit because there's more to a
refinance than just a lower rate you can
access cash consolidate debt upgrade
your home you can even skip two payments
save some extra money that way creating
greater upfront savings at the same time
think of the possibilities then make the
call to american financing uh right now
if you start soon you may close in as
fast as 10 days so it's simple it's easy
and uh you're also saving a lot of money
at the same time we could all we could
all stand to save some money i think
right now so here's what you got to do
call 866 569-4711
that's 866
569-4711 one more time 866 569-4711 or
visit americanfinancing.net
american financing nmls 182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org
for two years air travelers had to
endure an onerous and cumbersome charade
of pointless safety precautions uh well
actually uh air travelers have had to
endure an onerous and cumbersome charade
of pointless safety precautions for two
decades not just two years since the
turn of the century anyone who committed
the sin of trying to board a plane has
been treated like a suspected terrorist
and subjected to a type of scrutiny
screening and security screening
previously reserved for inmates at
maximum security prisons and that sort
of thing the only change over the past
two years is that now the millions of
suspected terrorists were also all
horribly diseased it was decided even
after the mass mandates were lifted
almost everywhere in the country still
you had to don a mass to get on a flight
in spite of the fact that the air inside
a plane is already aggressively filtered
the air is circulated through hepa
filters it's also pumped in from outside
the plane compressed by the engines and
sent into the cabin
so the air you breathe in the cabin of a
plane is completely replaced every three
minutes every three or four minutes it
is in other words
the cleanest and safest air you'll ever
breathe
in other words masking on a plane makes
the least sense and yet we masked on
planes for two years and kept masking
even after masking had ended almost
everywhere else that is until yesterday
u.s district judge catherine kimball
mazzell whose name shall be honored and
revered by frequent flyers for all of
eternity ruled that the cdc mask mandate
was unlawful because actually
slight little detail here they didn't
have the authority to impose mandates
minor details as far as the cdc is
concerned the cdc decided of course that
the pandemic gave it the authority to
act as legislature executive and
judiciary all at once but this judge
disagreed reading from the daily wire
report it says a federal judge in
florida has voided democrat president
joe biden's national mask mandate which
is in place at airports and covers
travel and airplanes and other forms of
public transportation quote the decision
monday by u.s district judge catherine
kimball-mozel in tampa also said the
centers for disease control and
prevention improperly failed to justify
its decision and did not follow proper
rulemaking the associated press reported
the cdc recently extended the mass
mandate which was set to expire on april
18th
until may 3rd to allow more time to
study the ba2 omicron subvariant of the
coronavirus that is now responsible for
the vast majority of cases of the u.s
missile who was appointed by former
president donald trump made the ruling
in a case that was filed by the health
freedom defense fund mizell ruled that
the mandate quote exceeded the cdt cdc's
statutory authority improperly invoked
the good cause exception to notice and
comment rulemaking and failed to
adequately explain its decisions
the ruling said that the court declared
the mandate to be unlawful because our
system does not permit agencies to act
unlawfully even in pursuit of desirable
ends
well we needed a judge to tell us that
that
that actually actually guys uh federal
government is not supposed to act
unlawfully
even if you think you have a really good
reason
but then something interesting happened
as soon as this was announced
within hours every major airline had
chosen to get rid of the masking
requirement
there was for about 30 minutes there was
a question of well what are the airlines
going to do because this just says that
they don't have to require masking but
they could still require masking if they
wanted to
well shortly after that they all dropped
the masking by 9 pm last night american
united delta southwest jetblue alaska
frontier and spirit had all announced
that they would not require masks on
planes anymore
um and actually went beyond that amtrak
dropped their masking requirement uber
dropped their masking requirement and
then video started flooding social media
of passengers learning the news about
the masking requirement being dropped uh
mid flights and erupting with joy so
here's one from a delta flight right
before takeoff when the captain
emerged from the cockpit to deliver the
good news himself watch
april 18th the dubai administration
announced that the transportation
security administration will no longer
enforce the federal mandate
requiring mass in all u.s airports and
onboard aircraft
[Applause]
finally effective immediately
immediately mass are optional for all
airport employees crew members and
customers inside us airports and onboard
aircraft
so lots of footage like that um there
have even been reports of flight
attendants
uh an airline staff weeping tears of joy
over the announcement which is
understandable you know i'd probably be
feeling the same way if i was forced to
mask every day at my job and not only
that but your your your whole job
becomes as has been the case for flight
attendants their whole job for two years
has just been enforcing the cdc's
mandate from asking that's all that's
all it was
all of a sudden it's just it's all about
the masking and that's all they did was
become the masking police
though i suspect that some of those
tears of joy were not actually joyful at
all uh you know this is a difficult time
for the petty tyrants in the flight
attendant community who quite obviously
relished the power that the mask mandate
gave them over other passengers which is
not all the flight attendants not even a
majority i would suspect but certainly
some of them
it's also a difficult time for these
so-called public health experts who
rightly see in the dropping of this
mandate
the last vestiges of their power and
relevance slipping away slipping out of
their grasp many of them have been on
twitter panicking over the judge's
ruling
their hysteria is nearly as sweet and
delicious as the panic last week over
elon musk's twitter bid it's not it's
not quite that good but it's still
really good so we'll go through a few of
these tweets and once again we'll have
to play some sad music accompaniment to
really sort of set the mood here so
here's dr jeremy faust he says hi united
when i bought my tickets for me my wife
who's pregnant and our unvaccinated
four-year-old i assumed you would
continue to have a mask mandate
now you cancel it and we'll have to
board our return flight under your new
your new no mask required policy
the idea of not waiting until vaccine
for all including kids under five
is pretty much you just saying it's cool
if a few kids die
so that you don't have to enforce this
for another month or two public health
advocate dr eric feigl ding tweeted i
will not be flying alaska air until they
reinstate public safety measures against
kova 19.
alaska air don't be an idiot airline and
let this happen american air your fellow
one world alliance member you're being
warned too
don't end up like your other uk one
world partner british airways
[Music]
then stanford infectious disease dr
abrar karen said
dropping public mask mandates on travel
where people are literally packed
together when they're traveling to
different places where they may seed
more transmission while we're greatly
under detecting cases as evidenced by
wastewater is a costly mistake at this
time
and then maggie astor a climate reporter
at the new york times said
i can't stop thinking about people who
may have chosen a book and board this
flight based on a personal risk
assessment that involved everyone being
masked and then mid-flight when it was
physically impossible to leave
that element of their risk assessment
was upended
well first of all it's not physically
impossible to leave in the middle of a
flight
you can do it i mean it's not
recommended but you can
she's right you know um i can't stop
thinking about those people either and
um laughing at them
my only regret is that i wasn't on a
plane when this was announced and
sitting right next to a coveted paranoid
person so that i could take my mask off
and force them to sit there trembling in
fear helplessly staring at my hideous
naked face for the duration of the
flight i would have i would have enjoyed
that so much i would have relished it
and it's not because i'm a jerk
well it's a little bit because i'm a
jerk but mostly
it's that the only hope
for these people and their long-term
psychological health and well-being is
that they are thrust against their will
back into a normal world
where people go about their business and
live their lives unmuzzled
this is a kind of final band-aid off
moment for these people
and it will either cause a mental break
or it will be a wake-up call
and this is the fork in the road it's
time to go one way or another
you have a choice this is what i would
say to the coved paranoids out there
um
you've been living this way for two
years
you've disgraced yourself in so many
ways and humiliated yourself
and uh some of us will never really
forget it but you still have a choice
you don't have to be like this forever
this is your choice
everyone else has returned to normal
life a long time ago
some of us never left it
and and but you you can come with us and
just be a normal person again you can
it's an option
and this is this is the time of choosing
right now
are you going to be normal
or a paranoid mentally broken
freak for your entire life
another interesting thing to note here
is that so far
while the buy administration has
expressed disappointment over the
judge's ruling it has not announced any
plan to challenge it so far
and most likely i would guess the
administration will simply let this go
i mean they've seen all the videos of
people cheering on planes and tearing
their masks off
they know that we're headed to the
midterms in fact i'm willing to bet that
this is exactly the outcome they were
hoping for
because it gets rid of the extremely
unpopular mask mandate but it frees them
from the responsibility of having to
lift it themselves
now they can point to the judge
blame her for killing your grandmother
call her a nazi or whatever and then
probably move on and pretend that the
whole masking thing never happened
it's the best possible outcome for them
politically
but remember something
even if the buying administration was
looking for a way out of this as i
suspect they were
the fact remains that out of all of the
tyrannical unjustifiable and unjustified
measures put in place ostensibly because
of covid
none of them were lifted abolished or
rolled back by choice
okay the people who put these policies
in place
all of these policies
the people who put them in place
never chose to get rid of them most of
it went away because the courts forced
the issue
and the rest because public backlash had
become too much of a political liability
for the regime
but
if the powers that be had their way
and if we'd all been more cooperative
though many of us were much more
cooperative than we ought to have been
but if it had worked how they wanted
we'd still be masking everywhere
and we'd be locked in our homes for most
of the day
subject to vaccine mandates and contact
tracing
that's what they wanted
it's not by their choice or their
consent that things ultimately worked
out differently
never forget that fact
because this is who rules us
they want us controlled muzzled tracked
traced and terrified
they didn't fully get their way this
time
but they'll try again
you can count on that now let's get to
our five headlines
[Music]
well you know if you've been listening
to show for a while you know that i'm
i've been an activist against the lazy
grocery shoppers who don't put their
grocery carts away i have some tragic
news the grocery carts have attacked me
in my own car this is uh they were
finally getting their revenge
unfortunately when i was pulling out of
my parking spot a rogue grocery cart
crashed into my car leaving my front
bumper scratched
there are two lessons that we can take
away from this one
don't be lazy and put your shopping
carts away so i don't have to suffer and
two you can solve an issue like mine and
this completely real story that i'm
telling you quickly and without breaking
the bank by just visiting rockauto.com
they have touch-up paint and pens that
are as easy to use as a magic marker
rockauto.com is an online family-owned
business that sells all auto parts you
could ever possibly need and that are
specific to your own vehicle their
prices are shockingly reasonable and
their shipping is quick so no matter
what's going on with your car you can
trust rock auto to get what you need
fast rock auto has a very user friendly
website and they make it very easy to
pick the right parts for your specific
car you'll see photo specs and even
installation tips so you can feel
confident that you're choosing the
correct parts for your vehicle so what
are you waiting for go to rockauto.com
for your auto parts needs today and
write walsh in there how did you hear
about this box so they know that i'm the
one that sent you that's rockauto.com to
shop for your auto parts
all right so tell me if this makes me a
bad person um over the weekend on
saturday
my wife went out for a bit and while she
was gone my kids decided that um they
wanted to play a prank on her and um
they're my kids so they have a of course
a really morbid sense of humor so the
prank that they settled on
this was their idea it was not mine okay
i want to make that clear i i didn't
come up with this
they did
and the prank was to pretend that my
daughter julia had been grievously
injured um that's what they wanted to do
and um and now i may have suggested that
some ketchup could be used
you know to simulate blood
that was my only suggestion and i did
say to them i said kids i
i don't approve of this this is not your
your mom's not gonna like this
but you could use ketchup too that'll
make this a little bit more realistic
and uh that's all i suggest that was it
and so they took that and they kind of
smeared it on uh on on julia's face
and it looked really convincing actually
and uh then my wife came home and my
daughter she did a great acting job for
about five seconds
uh but she broke after about five
seconds and started laughing um
but there was five seconds of uh well my
wife was not too amused by the whole
thing i don't think
but like i said it wasn't my idea
and i just you have to understand
because i know you're thinking well
you're the father you know don't you
have control of this and usually i do
but i this this was this was really it
was more it was kind of
ethical turmoil for me because i have
it's just my principles
will not allow me to interfere with a
good prank
and the way this was shaping up it's
like it was pretty good
and so i couldn't i couldn't i i could
not allow myself to stop them you have
to understand
that's the case i'm making anyway all
right let's see so joe biden
um had his own um
fun over the weekend especially on
sunday with the easter egg roll
which is a tradition at the white house
one of the many dumb traditions that
they should probably just get rid of
especially when you have a president
with dementia
and uh the the the you know the least we
see that the most that we can we can
keep him out of out of public view i
think the better but um
he was there and there are a lot of
videos that have surfaced and we'll play
some of them
of joe biden being
kind of shuffled around
and verbally prompted
told what to do and say
by first his wife so here's uh
the first clip of jill biden and joe
biden reading a book to the kids
and jill kind of nudging her husband
along let's listen to that
okay
just stay
steady just sit don't worry
she's a teacher i'm the teacher you know
he's a teacher
just stay like a no big deal it's the
present united states
the guy is supposed to be running the
country and he's being treated
literally like a dog okay just stay stay
boy stay right there
and then uh he was also prompted when to
wave to the crowd play that
thank you and happy happy easter
all right
[Applause]
here
there okay you could hear her say wave
wave now here's here's the one thing
i'll say um
my one slight defense of joe biden and
it's not much of a defense i will say
that this is kind of what my wife does
with me at social functions
not quite this bad i don't need as much
instruction but she does kind of
have to prompt me like this smile he's
supposed to smile here you know just
like basic basic social things you're
supposed to do in social situations
sometimes i need my wife to to help me
along so this is something that i think
wives do for husbands
um
and so if that was all we saw just those
two videos
i could almost let it go
uh
but that's not it because it wasn't just
jill biden
instructing
joe biden it was also the easter bunny
so here we have um
a couple of clips of the easter bunny
let's just play these
of the easter bunny coming in and uh
having to kind of give stage directions
to joe biden go ahead and play this
pakistan
and afghanistan
[Music]
he was babbling something about uh about
afghanistan in iraq and the middle east
and
uh quickly the easter bunny was over
there to intercept him and just point
him off in a different direction just go
yeah go wander over there mr president
just go on over there and then he did
wander over there and then the easter
bunny had to come in again and um direct
him in a different
to go in a different direction watch
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
this is not funny at all this is not
funny at all this is the present united
states
who's being led around confused hapless
being led around by the easter bunny
it couldn't even be like i'd feel a
little bit better if it was santa claus
at least santa claus is a person i think
right
you know but it's the easter bunny of
all the mythical holiday creatures the
worst one
also the creepiest one to have actually
running the show
turns out that easter bunny is that's
the question we've all had right for uh
the last
year two years is is uh who actually is
running the country who's running the
white house because we sure as hell no
it's not this guy
and turns out it's the easter bunny
and the other question was okay who is
the person in the easter bunny outfit
and it turns out that
no it wasn't some intern or whoever you
think probably usually with these events
they just take some lowly intern and
they put them in the easter bunny outfit
and send them out there but um this time
they had an actual a high-ranking
staffer in the easter bunny outfit
which um
i don't know for sure but i greatly
suspect is not what they what the white
house usually does but i gotta take
someone like a staffer who has an actual
office in the white house
this is someone in the you know kind of
the pr department at the white house
they're not gonna take them and put them
in the easter bunny outfit
they did that so that the easter bunny
could keep keep tabs on on
the present united states
because the president united states has
is senile and has dementia
and that was the case
before
he even became president when he was
running for office everybody knew it
and still tens of millions of americans
said yeah you know what that's the guy i
think we want to put him in charge
i don't know how many times i i have to
say it i'm going to keep on saying it
you know there's there is i have yet to
hear
and i've been advocating for this
for years and no one has explained to me
why there is not an upper age limit on
the presidency why do we not cap it at
75 at least i mean you could make an
argument for capping it at 65 or 70.
um but 75 okay 35 to 75 you've got 40 40
years to become president how is that
not enough time if that's not enough if
you can't do it in 40 years then it
wasn't meant to be go home and be with
your grandkids
what's the argument against it
now
i know what the real reason is
i know what the real reason i know why
we don't have an age limit on the
presidency because the people who who
would have to put the age limit in place
a lot of them it's you know they're the
ones who want to leave the possibility
open for them to become president
so we would need in order to have an age
limit placed on the presidency we would
need the people in charge of the country
to
choose to limit their own power and
they're never going to do that
and the problem is that each of them
individually they all feel that hey i
could run the president when i'm 90.
they all think that they are eminently
capable
and that they alone should be running
the show
which is precisely the reason why they
shouldn't be
so that's the real reason why the age
limit will never be put in place but is
there an actual argument
a good argument that anyone can
articulate
as to why there's no upper age limit
you know i said this again on twitter
yesterday and kira davis is a managing
editor over red state which is another
conservative publication
and she
she responded with
i don't think this is a good argument
but it's really the only one that i ever
hear she says uh matt walsh this isn't
fair i think the closer you get to 75
the more you'll see that the potential
wisdom of a man at that age cannot be
replaced by youth
if he's healthy and engaged and alert
age shouldn't be an issue
look at betty white worked till 90.
is this the way the argument always goes
and there's always some random example
of of a much older person who was okay
sometimes betty white is used a lot of
times somebody says oh my my great
grandfather he was uh spry and sprightly
and
he was real with it all the way to 95.
well not denying that but betty white
was you know appearing on tv every once
in a while
doing some celebrity appearances
she was working like part-time as an
actress
as an entertainer until 90 which is
impressive don't get me wrong
and she's very much an outlier i mean
most people don't even live to 90.
and the people who do
are not going to be as functional as
betty white was
but even betty white as an extreme
outlier
was just kind of working part-time as an
entertainer she wasn't running she
wasn't governing the country every
single day
that's the thing about being president
it's it's um
it is a 24-hour around-the-clock job
usually
i mean with joe biden it's not because
he goes to bed at about 6 30. you know
he sleeps for 12 hours
he takes uh four different he takes four
vacations a month it seems like
because he's not physically capable of
enduring the uh the burden of the office
but normally what it is and what it
should be is a 24-hour job so
at the age of 80.
like
is there ever going to be a time
when the person best suited
to take on
what is normally the one of the most
stressful and difficult jobs on planet
earth
is there ever going to be a time when
the person best suited for that is 80
years old
i'll tell you something if there is ever
a time when the person best suited for
the presidency is 80 years old then it's
over we might as well just pack it in
and give up the country's over
like there's nobody under the age of 80
who's qualified and uh would be able to
do it
well then we're screwed so
we might as well not even have a
president
we don't have one now in fact
all right um so yesterday was tax day
which brings us to this article from
reason magazine says this year americans
will spend an estimated 6.5 billion
hours trying to file their taxes
according to a new analysis by the
american action forum a non-profit that
has been tracking the burden of tax
related paperwork since 2017 the
aggregate time it takes for americans to
comply with income tax paperwork
according to aaf's tracker has fallen a
bit in recent years but the overall cost
of compliance has kept on growing this
year the group estimates americans will
spend more than 200 billion dollars just
trying to pay their taxes
now to clarify there that's not that
americans are going to spend
collectively 200 billion dollars in
taxes
now it's more like two trillion dollars
in taxes but 200 billion dollars
collectively just to pay them
like paying for services and paying for
accountants and whatever else in turbo
tax to do your taxes for you
um
that's an insane amount of added expense
being put toward no productive ends
whatsoever much of the complexity and
paperwork of paying federal income taxes
flows from the federal government's
effort to tax income many times
grover norquist president of americans
for tax reform a physically conservative
nonprofit that advocates for lower taxes
tells reason
income is taxed quote once you earn it
again if you invest and receive interest
or capital gains again if you invest in
a company that is subject to the
corporate income tax and again if you're
improving imprudent enough to die
if they taxed your income one time when
you received it as an income it would be
simpler and it would be less damaging to
your privacy
some of that complexity is the result of
a natural result of a tax system that
attempts to do a lot more than simply
collect the revenue necessary to run the
federal government the tax tax code
attempts to balance fairness
enforceability efficiency and other
goals that are often in conflict with
one with one another
um
yeah we hear i think this is an
interesting angle to
analyze here because
uh
we often hear complaints about how much
we all have to pay in taxes
and those are very much justified
complaints
but just the amount of time
the lost hours
spent
paying taxes and the money spent paying
that's because of how complicated it is
that's a travesty in its own right
and yeah as the article points out
the income taxes themselves
are much more complicated than they
ought to be or need to be
because your income you know one stream
of income is being taxed about 50
different ways
um
and that's part of the problem but i
think the underlying problem is the
income tax itself
and this is another thing that
of course the people in power are not
going to talk about
because if you get rid of the income tax
then that means less power and control
for them getting rid of the income tax
it means you don't need the irs anymore
and if you go to a consumption tax model
then you really don't need the irs
and without the irs without the income
tax it's again the people in power are
if they were to abolish income tax in
the irs they would be choosing to
significantly limit their own power
which they're not going to do
of their own free will and volition
but among we the people
you know this should be something that
we talk about a lot more than we do
look the federal government revenue i
haven't i didn't i didn't look it up but
i think in 2021 you can fact check me on
this
i think in 2021 um
federal government revenue was about
four trillion dollars
and
that's the amount of money
that they collected
all told from us
four
trillion
in one year
and then they end up spending even more
than that
um of that is that all from income taxes
no
about 40 to 50 is income tax so let's
say 2 trillion
get rid of the income tax completely and
that leaves them 2 trillion a year to
run the
government do you think is is it
possible at least do you think
to run a government on a paltry two
trillion dollars
i mean two trillion dollars is is more
if you were to have that in cash that's
more cash than exists on the entire
planet
is that possible to do
do you think they could figure out a way
can you run a government on on on just
two trillion dollars
well you certainly can but they don't
need to right now because they have the
income tax
which means that they're taking money
directly out of our wallets
and not just taking directly out of our
wallets but um you know that would be
bad enough
i wish it was just that i wish it would
have taken out just out of our wallets
but actually they take it directly out
of our paychecks
they go in they reach their grubby hands
and they take what they want from our
paychecks before we even see it and then
we get the leftovers
and this is uh this is a system that
we've all just sort of tolerated for
decade after decade
um
let's see next a professor at the
university of new hampshire david
finkelhor
had some thoughts to share recently
about pedophilia in a recent talk online
let's listen to that
also if young people are initiating
sexual activities with adults
or enthusiastically involved we can't be
effective in working with them
if we assume
that all such relationships start with a
predatory or criminally inclined
inclined adult
the
as we've seen in the discussion young
people bridle
at being forced into this
box of
being seen as being the victim of a
predator
and so there are
reasons for learning
about what the dynamics are and how to
talk about them so that we can
better help the young people who are in
these situations
now
you heard what he said with your own
ears um but as we so often learn while
you apparently what you you didn't hear
that you thought you heard it but you
didn't
now um
finkelhorn has uh which i his his name
somehow is just perfect given who this
guy is and what he's saying
uh daily wire has a report of this it
says fickelhorn told the daily wire on
monday morning that his remarks in the
libs of tick-tock clip were taken out of
context and that they were made in a
talk he gave on statutory sex crimes
against children noting that he clearly
said that all these kinds of crimes are
illegal and should be prevented well of
course the crimes are illegal that's why
they're crimes
well i clearly stipulated that crimes
are crimes well yeah we know that
um
but that's not really the point is it
he says the point that i was making was
that we can't identify them if we assume
that everybody who is sexually abusing
children is identifiable from the kind
of predator model where they had prior
sexual interest in children and they
were forcing themselves on a child
some pedophilic crimes occur according
to finkelhorn because young people and
adults are unaware of the statutory sex
crime laws and thus professionals should
spend more time educating people about
why this is a crime more time
discouraging young people from allowing
themselves to be seduced by an adult's
flattery and interest and more time
helping children understand why these
kinds of relationships don't work out oh
my gosh
this is him defending himself
this is after the fact okay this is like
a written statement he gives to the
daily wire defending himself
and claiming that all these you know
that everything's being taken out of
context and he wasn't really justifying
uh
child rape as much as it may seem like
that's what he was doing
but even in his own statement
let's listen to the words he's using
first of all he says that well a lot of
this stuff just a simple
misunderstanding
yeah adults having sex with kids they
just they didn't know they weren't
supposed to so we have to educate them
about that fact
and
if it can get worse than that it does
when he says that um
he first of all puts the blame
on the kids
saying that that we have to teach them
not to allow themselves to be seduced
by an adult's flattery and interest
now how about how about focusing on the
adults the predators
and and rather than trying to convince
them to
not be scumbag predators anymore we
we take them and we put them in these
facilities called prisons and we keep
them there
punish them
segregate them from society i think
that's a better might be a better option
but so he chalks up a lot of child rape
to a misunderstanding
he does
if the term victim blaming has any mean
means anything whatsoever
then
this has to be it
i mean this is this is victim blaming
this is the dictionary definition if it
has one
and then he says that um
we have to explain to children why these
kinds of relationships don't work out
they're not relationships first of all
okay relationship implies consent
a sexual relationship is something that
two willing
consenting
um people
choose to engage in
when a child's being raped by an adult
that's not a relationship
that's um that's rape that's abuse
and the problem isn't that they don't
work out
this is
and here's the thing
um
again
from this person this is his defense of
it but when he says he's being taken out
of context what he what he really means
and this is what they always mean when
they say that
uh i'll be taken out of context what
they actually mean is that we were not
supposed to hear that
yet
like we
in the mainstream public we were not
supposed to do that this was something
that he was having with this other
creepy uh some kind of creepy academic
conference thing and it was supposed to
live there
he wasn't they weren't ready to
introduce this to johnny public just yet
and so the
uh pedophilia
you know apologia that kind of thing
that's something that they're gonna
they kind of get it ready in these
academic circles
and then they filter it down
to the public
but they're not ready for us to see it
yet they haven't worked out all the
talking points just yet
and so the real complaint is that we saw
it
before we were supposed to
thanks in this case the libs of tick
tock who by the way will have more on um
on that in the daily cancellation
one other quick thing this is a tweet
from ben and jerry's ice cream um
i think by the way
keeping ben and jerry's in mind the
daily wire might need to start its own
ice cream
company as well so ben and jerry says we
are heartbroken by the loss of our
fellow vermonter fern feather
sadly she was another transgender person
targeted for
simply being herself
this was trending over the weekend
because ben and jerry's tweeted it and
other left-wing accounts which were
tweeting it about this transgender
person who was who was murdered and the
claim being made by ben and jerry's and
everybody else on the left is that this
was this was a hate crime this was
someone who was killed for being
transgender but yet
you read the article
that ben and jerry's linked to you
actually click on it and read it this is
what you see a few paragraphs down
you get to this
well first at the beginning it says the
killing of a transgender woman in
morristown drew outrage and condemnation
across vermont on wednesday heinsberg
resident fern feather 29 was found
stabbed to death along a morristown road
on tuesday morning according to vermont
state police
feather's death prompted an outpouring
of grief and anger from top state
officials and on social media house
speaker representative jill krawinski
said feather was tragically taken from
this world too soon like so many other
transgender people who are targeted
in bias driven attacks
krawinsky said we absolutely need to
continue to take steps to make vermont a
more equitable place and be clear that
hate has no place in our states
well yeah we know uh that
bigoted right-wing
cesspool of vermont
so this is the direct claim that they're
making that this person fern feather was
killed
for being transgender
yet you read a few more paragraphs down
this is what it says
prosecutors have charged seth brunell 43
with second-degree murder in feather's
death brunel who
was not known to have a fixed address
had been spending time with feather
before the killing roughly two hours
before feather's body was found
officers with the sheriff's department
had encountered the pair in a car
together in the parking lot
um
deputies checked on feather and burnell
and waited for them to leave the parking
lot upon his arrest brunel told police
that he had been defending himself
against feather who made a sexual
advance and attacked him
investigators observed no injuries or
evidence of a struggle or an assault on
brunel
now the point is i have no idea whether
this self-defense claim is true or not
whether he's telling the truth i don't
know
but there is nothing in that description
of the crime
that indicates at all that this was a
hate crime
there is right now
zero evidence
none that this person was killed for
being transgender
just that they were killed that they
were a transgender person who now uh
sadly is dead
and the way that the left does this now
is it is that the simple fact that a
transgender person was killed is itself
evidence of a hate crime
and that's why you can read articles
like on um
when i just had pulled up from pbs
this was at the end of last year
and it said uh with nearly two months
left 2021 has shattered the record of
transgender homicides in a year with 45
to date according to the human rights
campaign
last year held the record with 44 trans
murders
um and this was there were a lot of
headlines towards the end of last year
but i was the deadliest
uh year quote unquote the deadliest year
on record for transgender people and and
and these are all hate crimes
except that's just that's the number of
transgender people who are murdered
period across the across the entire
country for an entire year 45
and the claim is
what that with without without hate
crimes
no transgender person would ever be
murdered
like there's there's no other reason why
a trans person would ever be killed
so you we get rid of the hate crime
problem and no trans people are would be
immune from murder
of course that doesn't make any sense at
all
given that murder is uh something that
happens in sadly in every community in
america
you take any group of people any
demographic
and in a given year a certain portion of
them are going to be murdered
just because they're human beings living
in a society where this sort of thing
happens
that is not itself evidence of a hate
crime
now if you were to whittle that down you
take that 45 number and you look at it
and you look at each individual case how
many of them
out of the 45
how many of them were proven to be
actual hate crimes as in the person was
killed for being transgender and what
you find is that it's a vanishingly
small number
vast majority of people murdered for who
are transgender it's domestic disputes
drug related prostitution related in
other words it's the same reason why
most murders occur
against most demographics of people
those are the facts not that it matters
at all of course to the left let's get
now to the comment section
[Music]
turquoise 770 says um
matt likes his christian music and
unintelligible rarefied latin and dead
cathedrals that no one goes to except as
museums
well
unironically
yes uh easy bake oven says jazz jennings
had the same thing happen no sexual
function and not enough growth for the
surgery instead of the colon surgery he
had an even more experimental surgery
using the lining of his stomach for
length it ended up rupturing and there
have been multiple revision surgeries
since then
it's horrifying
yeah that's the really
interesting but tragic thing about the
about jazz jennings is that jazz
jennings has been
paraded around in front of cameras his
entire life
i mean since he was like five or six
years old
his parents decided that he was really a
girl who started and started
you know um and and put him on camera
and he hasn't been off camera since
wrote books about him and everything
like consigned him to this fate
talk about a signed
gender
they assigned the female uh identity
false identity to him
and
but if you track his story over the
years especially into adulthood
um
you see what a total disaster it's been
for him
especially with all these surgeries and
all these complications
and yet he's still traipsed out as a as
a trans success story it's the exact
opposite
let's see megan says
um
i don't understand how you could be
happy or unemployed maybe my fellow
millennials and zoomers have a lot more
savings than i do but every day that i'm
unemployed my stomach hurts as i watch
accounts slowly empty and the bills pile
up
well i think the the younger people who
we talked about in that poll who said
that they'd rather be they'd rather not
have a job and be happy um i don't think
it's because they've worked really hard
and they have a lot of savings and
they're going into early retirement i
think it's because they're not worried
about the bills because they have
someone who's going to take care of the
bills for them whether it's their
parents or it's the taxpayers or some
combination of the two and also it's not
that they're happier
because you're right you're not gonna be
happier uh when you're you know when
you're not doing anything productive
when you're not performing any any any
kind of labor in your life at all um
especially as a younger person
that's one thing if you're a tie if
you've lived a life and you've worked
really hard and uh you get to towards
the end of it and you retire i mean
that's one thing but even even then
a lot of older people find it very
difficult in retirement when they've got
when they've sort of got nothing to do
and they're looking around for something
to do and they have to you know
if they're going to have a happy
retirement they have to
dedicate those energy somewhere take up
a hobby do something
um to try to do that when you're young
kind of drop out of the workforce
and dedicate yourself to a life of
leisure it's just you're not gonna have
happiness doing that but you can have
numbness so not gonna be happy
but they can be distracted and numb and
i think that's the
most people a lot of people anyway elect
that instead of happiness
because it's easier
micah says i couldn't help but laugh as
matt said a dolphin got stabbed
i couldn't help but laugh
you're even worse than me pretending
that my children are injured to prank my
wife
also why do you take a stance of letting
pandas be destroyed but are not okay
with a dolphin getting stabbed
matt please explain
well you know my my opinion on pandas is
that they're totally useless and the
only reason that they're still alive is
that we've kept them around simply
because they're cute now um according to
some people are cute anyway
dolphins we do have laws in place and
and uh you know some of them are
endangered species
but these are also highly evolved
animals that can you know for the most
part fend for themselves
they're not dumb and clumsy and with
with no defense mechanisms
mechanisms at all like like pandas so i
think they they deserve to
be around anyway
do they deserve to have more legal
rights than human babies do well no they
don't of course not
sports are not the place for politics or
virtue signals and nba star jonathan
isaac is one of the few professionals
that knows this well isaac faced heavy
criticism from the media for not buying
into the political theater over the past
few years and still stood strong which
is why i'm extremely excited to announce
that he's decided to write a book
with daily wire called why i stand
jonathan's book will be about the rise
of his basketball career his journey
into faith and his strength to stand
alone in the face of immense pressure
the book is available for pre-order now
at amazon so reserve your copy today now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well if you've been listening to this
show for any length of time you've
almost certainly heard me mention the
libs of tick tock account on twitter i
mention it because that's where i get
like 75 percent of my show prep but also
because the person running the account
is easily among the top three
journalists in america now granted
almost all journalists these days are
morally bankrupt propagandas so it's not
a very stiff competition but still the
woman behind the libs of tick tock
account performs a valuable
journalistic service
her primary focus as the twitter handle
suggests is tick-tock she finds insane
leftist drivel on that platform and
calls attention to it and this is
important and i imagine rather
emotionally exhausting
work not just because the videos she
finds are often morbidly hilarious
though they are but because tick tock is
by far the most popular social media app
among the younger generations and by
revealing the sorts of things that are
posted on tick tock she's pointing the
spotlight into the disturbing and often
rather baffling environment where
millions of kids are being molded and
formed
i mean social media isn't just an app on
a phone it's where people especially
kids
live
it takes priority over what we would
call the real world
but to them tick tock is a much realer
world than anything they encounter in
three-dimensional space and they care
more about it
that's why it's important for us to know
what's going on there i would think also
sites like tick tock are kind of a far
left staging ground
if you're plugged into that world you'll
have a jump on the new leftist ideas and
talking points before they make their
way into the mainstream
this is an extremely fast process you'll
hear some extravagantly pierced
blue-haired weirdo on tick-tock spouting
the latest insanity and a week later
it'll be an official democrat talking
point as the pipeline from leftist
extremism to leftist mainstream is not
very long at all but it can be helpful
to get the heads up anyway so for
example for example libs of tick tock
posted this yesterday it's a video from
non-binary activist and all-around creep
jeffrey marsh
giving what will soon become the
official answer to the what is a woman
question listen
is madison cawthorne's definition of a
woman
x chromosomes no tally whacker
and this gives me a chance to talk about
biological essentialism
um first of all it's not true people
have all kinds of chromosomes and all
kinds of bodies women who've had
hysterectomies people born with certain
conditions but that's almost immaterial
number two
it is a system of oppression
gender is a hierarchy
and a system of oppression and the
easier it is to define gender the easier
it is to keep the oppression
going
it's dangerous
now uh by the way people do not have all
kinds of chromosomes women have xx
chromosomes men have xy chromosomes
that's the setup now the fact that a
very small number of people suffer from
genetic or abnormalities or deformities
which in those specific cases may make
the chromosomal situation somewhat more
muddled does not change the fact that in
principle men have xy chromosomes and
women have xx chromosomes there was a
case in 2006 of a chinese baby born with
a very rare birth defect that gave him
three arms
but this medical anomaly does not
invalidate the principle that human
beings have two arms
if somebody asked you how many arms do
human beings have it would be insane to
act like the question is unanswerable
just because the one kid in china had
three
okay but the real point for marsh is the
second thing you mentioned where uh you
know and i think we're gonna start
hearing this a lot more and he says the
question itself is oppressive even
dangerous
because gender is a system of oppression
the thing about that is you know if
gender is a system of oppression
then why aren't we getting rid of it and
just going back to talking about sex
male and female
why isn't he advocating that we see
ourselves simply as male and female and
within those categories people can dress
however they want and be as feminine or
masculine as they want wouldn't that be
the way to break down the oppressive
gender system
leftist radicals are the ones who
invented it anyway they came up with the
idea that gender is distinct from sex
why did they invent it if it's
oppressive and why do men insist on
being seen as women and women as men if
the whole thing is oppressive
none of this makes any sense of course
but it's where leftist discourse is
headed and it's why these videos are
important
of course libs of tick tock has done
more than post tic toc videos uh online
though they she also has especially in
recent months had a hand in breaking
major stories about the grooming
indoctrinating going on in our school
system and i suspect it's this last
thing
you know revealing what's happening the
school system that especially put her in
the sights of the elites who've grown
tired of being exposed and humiliated by
some anonymous account on twitter and
that's why they've now made sure that
the account is no longer anonymous this
morning the washington post ran a major
headline story which serves no other
purpose than to dox the woman behind the
libs a tick tock account
headline says
meet the woman behind libs of tech talk
secretly fueling the rights outrage
machine a popular twit twitter account
has morphed into a social media
phenomenon spreading anti-lgbtq plus
sentiment and shaping public discourse
now the article goes on to provide the
full name of the woman behind the
account the city where she lives
her employment history with originally
with a link to her employer
and they took the link out
but originally it was there
and it attempts of course to also link
her to january 6th because why not
the post reporter acknowledges that the
owner of the account has taken a number
of steps to keep her identity private
she obviously wants to be private she
wants to be anonymous
but the washington post revealed it
anyway
and this is where it's important to
mention that the reporter who wrote this
article is none other than taylor lorenz
now you may remember her from a few
weeks ago when she was crying on msnbc
about being harassed and doxed let's go
back and relive that moment again
i've had to remove every single social
tie i had severe ptsd from this i i
contemplated suicide it got really bad
you feel like any little piece of
information
that gets out on you will be used by the
worst people on the internet to destroy
your life
and it's
so isolating
and terrifying
it's horrifying
i'm so sorry
it's overwhelming it's really hard
yes it's very bad when information gets
out that may be used against you
said the journalist literally a week
before she wrote an article doxing an
anonymous twitter account
this is exactly why you can't take the
tears seriously from these people
i doubt that these goblins are even
capable of experiencing real human
emotion anymore anyway
but if they are i hope that the backlash
lorenz gets for her libs of tick tock
expose is severe
i hope it makes her cry herself to sleep
every night for the next year
i hope it ruins her life some more
because that's justice it's what she
deserves
the only good news for her is that the
worst people on the internet aren't
going to come after her because she and
her friends are the worst people so the
worst thing that can happen to her is
that the second worst people go after
her
maybe that'll be some consolation i
don't know
but we know why lorenz wants to make a
victim of herself she believes that her
tears give her license that they are her
credentials basically
which are supposed to confer upon her
moral superiority they're supposed to
make her untouchable and above criticism
after all what sort of monster would
criticize a woman with ptsd
well i will
her trauma doesn't mean anything to me
because it's not real she deserves it
anyway
the more interesting question then is
why they are going after libs of tick
tock in the first place
all the account does is simply repost
content
and it's not like she's digging through
dumpsters to find the content
okay and she's not doing what taylor
lorenz had to do
to find the um the person behind the
live tick tock account had to actually
do some digging to find it she's not
doing that
liv's a tick tock she's going to one of
the one of the biggest social media
platforms in the world and she's just
reposting it
she's taking content that other people
put on this social media platform
because they wanted people to see it
and she's amplifying it
you know people on the left do that with
me all the time they take my videos and
things that i've said
and um
you know things i've said on the show
and they they
reap the media matters does it all the
time i don't have a problem with that
i mean i want people to hear what i'm
saying
and that's all the lives of tic tac is
doing so why target her
well that question is also very easy to
answer
as the saying goes sunlight is the best
disinfectant and she is helping to shine
a light into some pretty dark spaces
spaces that taylor lorenz and the
washington post would prefer to keep out
of the mainstream view
they will in fact do anything to keep it
out of you as lorenz has clearly
demonstrated
and that's why she is today finally
canceled
again and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadowsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. today on the ben shapiro show joe
biden is wrangled by the easter bunny
while jill tells joe when to wave plus
democrats begin making preemptive
excuses for a 2022 wipeout and a judge
finally knocks down the cdc's mass
mandate on airplanes that's today on the
ben shapiro show give it a listen